[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen micro fällt meine lieben
freunde ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet
perfekt
wie soll ich den im rundling
na ja meine lieben freunde ihr seht es
auf jeden fall bereits im titel
eingeblendet denn heute werden wir uns
endlich mal wieder um die
strandvilla
so episch wie ist jetzt angekündigt habe
wird es nicht allerdings habe ich mir
eine menge notizen gemacht denn ich habe
den kommentaren gelesen in stuttgart
könnte sich mal wieder darum kümmern das
ding ist eine neverending baustelle
ehrlich gesagt da muss mal was passieren
von daher meine lieben freunde blende
ich euch auch direkt zu beginn mal eben
fixen time lab sein wie ich nehme ich
auch jetzt noch das schweinefleisch drin
was ich mehr zwangsläufig machen muss
immerhin ich ja gestorben bin
ich werde euch auf jeden fall eine ganz
kurze time bleibt eben ein werden wie
ich meine ganzen dinge jemand vorbereite
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe gerade
zehn minuten lagen die ganzen dinge
zusammengefasst die ich benötige für die
planung für die standorte
der hat mein komplettes outfit an
was kriege ich ja nicht den von hier
treffe
[Musik]
freilich kann ich das projekt jetzt
schon beenden ich habe gerade auf jeden
fall die ganzen dinge zusammengesucht
die ich für das interieur der standorte
benötige wenn ich da als auch mein tag
ich habe hier wirklich eine menge sachen
am start ich habe quasi am start
allerdings auch quatsch stufen ich habe
so ein bisschen dekomaterial am start
die sache ist allerdings dass mir noch
zwei dinge fehlen und das ist erstens
ein bisschen mehr hellgraue wolle weil
ich noch eine hellgraue banner machen
muss wenn mein kleiderschrank in der
standort villa und ich benötige schnee
denn der schnee wenn er alt so kleine
paletten artig gestartet es sieht ganz
gut aus als besitz weil das ein bisschen
flacher ist als eine quartz stufe um die
generell schon sehr viel aus quarz
gebaut haben von daher seht ihr auch
schon vielleicht nicht immer ein studium
sondern zu den bergen hier freunde wir
haben nämlich obendrauf auch schnee und
das geht ein bisschen schneller mit
unserem unterwassertunnel mit unserer
kleinen ic strecke apropos ic strecke in
das video gerade seht bin ich in berlin
und muss einfach von hamburg nach berlin
mit dem auto fahren ich liebe zu fahren
das gut für die umwelt blabla und man
fährt auch von hamburg nach berlin nur
eineinhalb stunden mit dem zug mit dem
auto aber das doppelte drei stunden na
ja meine bahn streikt auf jeden fall
nicht die läuft die ganze zeit
allerdings müsste ich hier jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen schnee wirklich einsammeln
und während ich den schnee einsammeln
und kann ich auch ganz kurze zeit nutzen
um mich mal eben dafür zu entschuldigen
das gestern nicht dieses video kam
sondern das ist jetzt heute erst kam das
ist voll und ganz mein fehler und der
fehler von dem bahnfahrer
ich will überhaupt nicht helfen gerade
das hört sich so an als ob das ihren
kompletter deutsche bahn hält werfe ich
glaube die haben damit gar nichts zu tun
die sache waren nämlich dass wir nach
hamburg gefahren sind und dann kamen wir
an und das habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch
schon in meiner instagram story gesehen
falls mir dort folgt ich werde es euch
hier mal ein er war zum zug er hat sich
mal gedacht mensch ich bin mal vier
kilometer lang kommen oft schon klinge
aus china und fahr drei kamen habe und
dann standen wir da ganz entspannt für
weiß ich nicht nur stunde
anderthalb war mega entspannt auf jeden
fall also wenn irgend jemand von euch
nach hamburg fährt fahrrad auf jeden
fall nicht hinten durch den hafen durch
ich weiß nicht ob das wiederum tag
erwischt amboss gerade irgendwie abgeben
dass da irgend wer weiß ich nicht das
gros verladen musste oder was weiß ich
aber das war auf jeden fall der grund
warum ich gestern dieses video hier
leider nicht mehr geschafft habe und
worauf ich auch noch mal ganz kurz
eingehen wollte waren nicht einige
kommentare sondern einkommen da habe ich
dazu eigentlich nur gesehen und zwar
wurde mir geschrieben ich weiß nicht ob
ich ihnen jetzt wieder finde weil ich
das gestern abend gelesen habe als ich
im bett lag und auch ein bisschen
kommentare beantwortet habe unter den
videos ich kenne ihn deswegen glaube ich
nicht wiederfinden oder jetzt einblenden
die sache ist allerdings dass dort
geschrieben wurde 'mensch luca gegen wie
waren die ersten folgen deutlich
interessanter als die jetzigen folgen
und da bin ich auch ganz ehrlich das
liegt auch an mir denn es ist natürlich
sommer und andere youtuber machen gerade
sommerpause oder andere popstars da
machen auch gerade sommerpause und ich
hab mir gedacht mensch ich mag das
eigentlich ich liebe es durchzuziehen
ich liebe meinen beruf warum muss ich
dann eine sommerpause machen allerdings
ist glaube ich alles in der medienwelt
wie auch selbst beobachten könnte gerade
ein bisschen runter gefahren weil viele
leute natürlich aufgrund von corona auch
drinnen waren viele sachen liefen extrem
gut jetzt gerade geht ziemlich wieder
alles müssen runter
ich glaub ich auch gerade im flieger
eingeatmet ich finde immer das beste
beispiel um so was halt zu sehen ist
twitch und die leute die sonst immer
ziemlich krasse trips hatten
wenn man das dann halt quasi mit den
aktuellen zahlen vergleicht und wenn man
sich dann beispielsweise sonnen montana
blackcomb guckt er glaub ich mit einer
der größten streamer ist mit seinem 3
max und papa platte und keine ahnung was
die hatten halt alle vor einem halben
jahr so 60 tausend follower auf twitter
oder satz ich weiß nicht wie es heißt
und jetzt habe ich alle nur so um die
10.000 und ich finde daran sieht man
wirklich krass okay viele leute sind
gerade wieder auf dem weg nach draußen
sind eher bei dem wetter aktuell
irgendwie draußen unterwegs man kann
wieder reisen man kann wieder richtig
was unternehmen man kann wieder normal
in seinem sportverein sport machen viele
leute hängen einfach gerade nicht vor
den pcs vor den bildschirmen und daran
liegt natürlich auch so ein bisschen
dass die nachfrage nicht so krass da ist
natürlich auch das angebot ein bisschen
weniger wird und das angebot wird zwar
bei mir jetzt nicht großartig weniger
durch noch weiter meine videos
allerdings merke ich natürlich dass
viele leute jetzt aktuell eher sagen
mensch ich gehe jetzt mal raus oder ich
das wieder mal nachher viele aufrufe
mache ich gar nicht mehr genau um die
uhrzeit um mein gott okay ich hab's noch
gekriegt viele aufrufe mache ich gar
nicht mehr so genau dann um 20 uhr wenn
die folgen online gehen sondern erst am
nächsten tag dann irgendwie mal mittag
war auch dass sich viele leute erst
meine videos dann am wochenende angucken
wenn die woche vorbei ist
darauf wollte ich nur ganz kurz eingehen
das liegt allerdings natürlich auch an
mir also ich bin selber auch so ich
konnte mir selber gerade deutlich
weniger soziale medien ich hänge nicht
weniger am handy weil ich einfach viel
mit freunden unterwegs bin und ich
glaube das ist auch ganz schön und ich
will mich da auch nicht um gottes willen
darüber beschweren von wegen ein macht
nichts draus und cookie war meine
youtube-videos um gottes willen genießt
euer leben genießt die zeit gerade bevor
vielleicht der nächste locker und kommt
keine ahnung was allerdings sagen dass
zwei dinge auf die ich ganz gut eingehen
wollte also noch mal kurz
zusammengefasst sorry dass dieses video
ist heute kaum kommt und nicht gestern
das lag an diesem bahnfahrer und dann
habe ich nicht mehr geschafft das ganze
zu schneiden du bleibst hier stehen
bitte der hand immer wieder so zurück
warte ich muss mich einmal kurz hier
hinstellen glaube ich an mir ab bleibt
stehen perfekt ok darauf wollte ich auf
jeden fall ganz groß eingehen und die
tatsache dass eine oder andere mal
hinterher das projekt verliert ein
bisschen anfahrt ist aber auch finde ich
irgendwie nicht nur aufgrund von kona
verständlich und der sommer situation
und der sommerpause so ein bisschen auch
in der ganze medienwelt sondern finde
ich auch einfach weil das projekt jetzt
auch schon relativ lang geht mensch ist
hab ich mir gar nicht mehr mehr wolle
geholt aber da kann ich mal ganz groß im
river falls zutraue insel dass ich
gerade sagen wollte war dass es halt
nicht nur der jahreszeit gerade und der
generellen situation natürlich
geschuldet ist sondern das projekt
natürlich jetzt auch schon 85 folgen
lang läuft und viele dinge die ich zu
beginn machen wollte habe ich einfach
gemacht so diese anderen inseln hier so
ein bisschen besiedeln die strandhaus
villa dann mein portal schwert was ja
auch lange zeit auf absolutes der stand
der leuchtturm den man jetzt gar nicht
eingeblendet den ball zu weit weg ist
die strandhaus will hat sehr viele dinge
habe ich jetzt einfach schon gemacht ich
habe nichts groß mehr auf der to do
liste stehen von daher freue ich mich
auch einfach auf staffel 2 und dieses
projekt plätschert jetzt so ein bisschen
aus ist es so ein bisschen die sonne wie
sehr diese blöden ändern wenn die leute
hinsetzen es ist ein bisschen wie so
eine serie wo zu beginn gesagt ja das
ist unser bösewicht den müssen wir jagen
und wenn er böse wie ich dann zum ende
der ersten staffel gejagt wurde und dann
irgendwie tot ist beispielsweise danach
denkt man sich dann auch sehr okay was
ist jetzt und dann überlegt man sich
natürlich als regisseur oder als was
können wir vielleicht als nächstes
machen und genau so ist bei mir
natürlich auch zu den ganzen anfangs
sachen von wegen ja eine gute richtung
und mit diamanten finden und ein schönes
haus bauen habe ich gemacht und jetzt
habe ich alles weitere durch gebaut und
ich bin ganz ehrlich jetzt kann ich auch
guten gewissens ist das projekt in ein
paar folgen beenden nachdem wir dann
wirklich den nutzer besucht haben ich
habe sechs weise wolle perfekt das passt
super denn jetzt mal ganz kurz eben
zurück und müssen uns die wolle färben
denn das benötige ich für meine banner
für meinen kleiderschrank leerstand
ausbilder ich freue mich wirklich dass
wir heute das ding mehr oder weniger
fast fertig kriegen es wird
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz klappen weil
ich nur diesen raum hier fertig kriege
und den hier das was dahinter passiert
allerdings nicht
reitet das skelett die spinne oder steht
das skelett einfach nur hinter der
spinne ist aber auch egal leute wir
laufen auf jeden fall noch mal ganz kurz
ein bisschen reiten
er gut wissen angekettet wir laufen ganz
kurz mal wieder zurück beziehungsweise
wir hatten schon sehr sehr lange eine
trauerminute mehr wir nehmen uns jetzt
erstmal unseren hellgrauen farbstoff und
dann nochmal den und gehen hier den
schwarzen banner lager ich dann eben
ganz kurz denn ich benötige noch einen
farbstoff mehr perfekt ist hab ich sogar
zwei bekommen dann kann ich irgendwie
reinpacken und
das benötige ich noch nie was halt dumm
dass wir da noch mehr von gemacht habe
ich hätte es mich einfach so machen
können ist aber auch egal ich stehen ein
bisschen neben der spur ich aber auch
glaube ich ein bisschen
zu lange geschlafen ehrlich gesagt aber
es hat auch mal ganz gut getan also man
eben ganz kurz das ihr zur hellgrauen
wolle machen jetzt auch nicht sogar doch
noch mal mehr nicht im bild wartet man
farbstoff und weizen farbstoff packt das
soll hier rein und jetzt habe ich
hellgrauen farbstoff und jetzt habe ich
auch ich hatte ja schon wolle ok perfekt
dann habe ich mich vertan zürich stehen
bisschen neben der spur also einmal ganz
kurz das hier rein ich habe auch den
spott nicht am start der sport ist
nämlich hier so und das ganze jetzt noch
mal eben so und sodann haben nämlich den
hellgrauen banner können dementsprechend
uns den schwarzen weiter zurücknehmen
die hellgraue wolle kann hier ein device
wolle ich benötige ich auch nicht mehr
die partie jetzt einfach hierhin in
schwarzen trocken beton benötige ich das
habe ich alles die schnee blog da habe
ich allerdings muss sich die schneeberge
einmal ganz kurz so anordnen wenn ich
benötige diesem schnee den rest des
brauche ich allerdings nicht mehr und
ich bin nicht glaube ich auch schon
ausgerüstet die schwarzen glasscheiben
habe ich weder schon dass ich unten
herbert mit am start habe also unsere
behutsamkeit spitzhacke ich gehe mal
ganz kurz noch mal eben kurz schlafen
schweinchen die habe ich noch gar nicht
hallo gesagt du kannst
mich wenigstens einmal kurz angucken
ich gehe ganz fix war eben schlafen
damit wir nicht irgendeine komische
zombie situation gleich in unserer
strandhaus wähler haben so du einmal
ganz kurz aus und zeigt also meine
lieben freunde wir schreiben heute
geschichte denn das interieur der
standort villa wird eventuell doch
fertig gestellt ich habe mir jetzt auf
jeden fall gerade noch mal angeguckt wie
das ganze team aufgebaut sein soll ich
baue das ja wieder inspirative aufgrund
eines youtube-videos was ich gesehen
habe
allerdings könnte es tatsächlich sein
dass wir es noch schaffen weil ich
glaube dass in den hinteren raum dass
tatsächlich gar nicht so viel rein
kommen das wird mich das schlafzimmer
vielleicht schaffen wir das nachher auch
noch ich weiß nicht wie viele items sich
dafür benötige allerdings konnten wir
jetzt erstmal ganz gut
warum kommt die spieler auf mich zu
warum ich dachte spinnen tagsüber
greifen einig anja hast du vorhin schon
gesagt
einmal ganz kurz weg das waren heute
zwei macs hier
dank das verrottete fleisch meist ich
mal ganz kurz hierhin unsere ja das wäre
auch echt sehr wild wenn ihr mit der
yacht wirklich fahren könnten aber
vielleicht passiert ja was im nächsten
minecraft projekt mit mir in der staffel
zwei mal abwarten die sache ist dass ich
habe mit am start habe weil mir
aufgefallen ist dass das hier nur fünf
quartz blöcke sind und dass hier 123456
dementsprechend habe ich mich hier ein
bisschen verbaut und muss nun hier das
glas sekt nehmen und deswegen auch die
behutsamkeit spitzhacke da wenig dass
sie mit einer normalen spitzhacke
abbauen würde wir nicht die glasscheiben
bekommen werden von daher hier einmal
alles sagt abgebaut jetzt nehmen wir
unsere wo sind sie denn die glatten
quartz blöcke
bin ich dumm an der stelle kann ich die
öfen jahre dienst auch einmal ganz kurz
eben entleeren und hier vorne werden
jetzt meine platten fahrzeug neben
erstellt dann kann ich die items auch
mal ganz kurz wieder unsere kisten
packen ich regte echt extrem auf das
hier einfach so viele verdammte villiger
die ganze zeit rum laufen
ja arschloch so also das hatte ich mal
ganz kurz eben hier rein wir haben echt
eine menge redstone das war geil wenn
wir das irgendwie traden könnten wenn
die ideen habt schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
das quad an schweinefleisch habe ich
hier noch da wurden auch in die letzte
folge geschrieben irgendwo her so dass
ganz gebratene schweinefleisch oder
irgendwie sowas glaube ich da muss ich
ganz offen und zwar habe ich das ich
weiß ich hab ich das gezeigt habe
allerdings habe ich hier
schweinefleisch gebraten und mir einfach
ein bisschen essen geholt das habe ich
aber glaube ich auch gesagt doch
eigentlich in der letzten folge weil ich
das essen halt brauchte weil ich ja
zurück in netter muss noch nicht mein
ganzes anderes essen was nicht leicht
ich war also dementsprechend vegetarisch
nicht mehr hatte und das habe ich halt
verloren im netz deswegen habe ich mir
schweinefleisch gemacht und das ganze
kam auch von den vorbörslich getötet
habe also von diesem komischen
schweinen ich habe einen ganz kurzen
profil hier
ich sollte mir glaube ich öfter darüber
bewusst sein dass echte menge leute
meine videos gucken nur ziemlich
peinlich ist dass sich hier live popeln
vor der kamera sitze warten war noch
diesen blog hier eben einmal ab dann
haben wir nämlich genau 21 stück und das
sollte denke ich auch reichen für diese
kleine leiste die wieder neu aufbauen
müssen von daher nehmen wir mal unsere
glatten quartz glocke und können die
hier dransetzen perfekt das passt
perfekt zu den anderen blöcken und hier
runter so der zieht ihr schon dass das
hier ein bisschen proportionaler ist und
als allererstes kümmern wir uns jetzt
selbstverständlich erst mal um das
geländer das ist ja eigentlich eine
todesmaschine kannst du einfach
runterfallen zack kriegs schaden von
daher habe ich mir hier schwarze
glasscheiben geholt die man jetzt hier
einfach verbinden dran setzen kann die
gegen genau bis hier und da haben wir so
ein kleines geländer sieht auch ganz
geil ausfindig und jetzt arbeiten wir
zum ersten mal mit quartz säulen die
kommen nämlich genau hierhin also
1234 und hier neben auch mit zwei
blöcken abstand also 1234 die und
hinkommen nun quartz blöcke hin also die
normale nicht die glatten die sehen
nämlich manchmal ganz produziert im
vergleich zu zeigen mit einem glatten
fahrzeug gesehen so ein bisschen rohbaus
mit diesem streifen hier
man sieht keinen riesigen unterschied
allerdings hat er im video auch mit den
normalen gemacht und ich dachte er hat
auf jeden fall mehr ahnung davon von
daher macht es auch so und dafür da
drüber nehmen wir jetzt die glatten
quatsch stufen kann jetzt nicht einfach
so hier hinsetzen und dann haben wir
hier so ein kleines regal und genau das
gleiche machen wir jetzt auch hier auf
der anderen seite also hier wieder 1234
und hier auch ein zwei drei vier die
fackel hier kommt ab und dann jetzt hier
zwei quads blöcke und die glatten
quatsch stufen hier so nämlich nicht
perfekt so hin und so dann haben wir auf
beiden seiten jetzt quasi regal jetzt
nehmen wir allerdings unseren glatten
quartz blocken und setzten ihn nicht
hier und hier hin und dazwischen die
glatten quad stufen das passt jetzt
nämlich mehr mit den glatten quatsch
stufen das ja so eine kleine ablage auf
die wir hier auf die rechte seite 2 so
blumentöpfe setzen mit pflichten
setzlingen das soll so ein bisschen zu
dieser kleider bambus sein eventuell
adorno und hier links eine kleine
laterne in damit auch hier soll ein
bisschen beleuchtung am start haben nun
nehmen wir unsere an die sitzstufen
unsere glatten quad stufen die
steinstufen die glatten steinstufen und
den schnee denn nun machen wir hier so
ein kleines
sitzbereich section hin denn wir
benötigen hierfür erst mal die an die
sieht stufen die werden jetzt nämlich so
angeordnet zack zack zack zack zack in
die mitte eine glatte quatsch stufe und
jetzt kommen hier zwei sitze hin die
sache ist jetzt dass ihr sagen müsst wie
die aussehen sollen also nehmen wir
glatte steinstufen oder nehmen wir
normale steinstufen weil hier kommt der
schnee hin und hier auch dann habe ich
mich dann so leichte kleine lounge
sitzecken und haben halt hier vorne eine
stein sitzt situation hier hinten
glatten stein ich glaube ich würde es
jetzt mal bei dem glatten stein belassen
weil es so ein bisschen anders aussieht
wie dass sie das sieht schon sehr
ähnlich aus allerdings könnt ihr mir
gerne auch nicht unten in die kommentare
schreiben ob ihr das hier besser findet
oder die glatten stufen schade finde ich
jetzt endlich gesagt auf youtube dass
man keine umfragen mehr machen kann dass
wir nämlich sehr gerne dann könnte ich
auf eine umfrage machen könnt ihr
abstimmen dann kann man noch sagen
allerdings kann ich mir vielleicht für
staffel zweimal überlegen dass sich dann
mit seiner website immer umfrage mache
und dann könnt ihr da auch sachen
eintragen was ihr sehen wollt und so
weiter und so fort allerdings ist das
hier unsere kleine wohnzimmer sitzecke
und nun nehmen wir unseren schwarzen
trocken beton der bleibt auch trocken
beton also der wird jetzt nicht
irgendwie ein wasser gesetzt sodass es
normaler beton wird den sätzen wie mich
hier vornherein das soll der fernseher
sein und die sache beim fernseher ist
dass ich mir gedacht habe dass das
dingens das normale beton ein bisschen
zu glatt aussieht und so haben wir so
ein bisschen struktur zumindest sieht
auch so ein bisschen aus wie ein
störungsbild das finde ich ganz geil
darunter kommen nun an den sitzstufen
was so ein bisschen so das sideboard
darstellen soll nun nehmen wir unseren
toten busch die beiden eichen
laubblätter und unseren blumentopf und
werden hier in die ecke vom kleinen
bambus setzen ich weiß dass ich das
unten mit einem fass gemacht habe fand
ich auch sehr geil allerdings haben wir
hier oben ist schon ein bisschen wenig
raum und da sag ich ganz klar dass hier
noch ein bisschen luftiger aussieht nun
für die rechte ecke hier benötige ich
auch nochmal quad sollen so so und hier
oben noch einen drauf diesmal allerdings
drei blöcke abstand nämlich bis hierhin
das habe ich erst mal noch provisorisch
gemacht das brauche ich jetzt auch erst
mal ganz kurz wieder zu damit ihr wisst
wo die reise hingehen soll und hier oben
drauf wir wollen schon aufgefallen da
benötige ich normale quad stufen und
nicht die normalen weil ich glaube dass
das auch ein bisschen geile aussieht
wenn das dann so ein bisschen ja mehr
struktur hat da die sonne allerdings
herunter geht kann man das ganz gut auch
mit dem schlafen verbinden da vorne
haben wir auch immer noch unseren
acquisa tor
also dieses ding das da so leuchtet wie
eine laterne da wird mir auch in die
kommentare geschrieben luca was mit
einem aktivator baut ihn doch mal weiter
wie was willst du damit es überhaupt
machen die sache ist allerdings dass man
mit dem aktivator wirklich unter wasser
atmen kann und das bringt mir aktuell
nichts ich habe den unterwasser tunnel
fertig ich werde nichts weiter unter
wasser bauen event in staffel zwei ich
will ich die ganze zeit so hinz geben
auf staffel 2 und euch so unnötig weil
es ja auch noch ein monat safe dauern
wird weil wir noch 15 folgen hier haben
und danach mache ich auch erst mal ganz
kurz pause wohl auf ich überhaupt dahin
muss man ein schwein säge ich idiot
allerdings wird es sehr sehr geil ich
habe auf jeden fall eine menge ideen
schon vorbereitet nicht nur sachen die
ich bei der welt machen wollte also die
bauen wollte sondern auch dinge die
nicht ganz einfach
das sind sechs stufen nicht benötige ich
mal ein paar mehr sondern auch dinge die
ich dir haben auch schon gar nicht mehr
hier gepennt ich habe mal hier wieder
schlafen nicht dadurch bauen wollte in
meiner welt sondern auch dinge die ich
außen rum gestalten wollte also
vielleicht ab und zu auch mal einen gast
mit dabei
ich weiß nicht ob der bock auf
singleplayer oder multiplayer wird ja
auch mal die kommentare schreiben ich
plane gefühlt irgendwie gerade mehr
staffel 2 weil ich schon so bock darauf
habe als ich dieses projekt dennoch
plane wir haben hier ja auch schon viel
geschafft es geht ja gerade den letzten
folgen nur noch darum dass ich die
sachen die ich mir vorgenommen habe
jetzt auch fertig stelle beispielsweise
wie gesagt ich hab voll mein bildschirm
grad angebot harvey hat beispielsweise
diese strandvilla hier die ich halt noch
fertig bauen muss dann auch
beispielsweise ja noch das den
wasserfall die nicht bauen wollte auf
der anderen insel und so das sind ein
paar sachen wo ich gar nicht mehr weiß
ob ich überhaupt noch fertig kriegen
werde ich muss auch noch einen freund
fürs schafhof wildschwein holen das hab
ich mir auch versprochen allerdings wird
das auf jeden fall gemacht ich hoffe
dass ich das hinkriege und dann am ende
natürlich muss ich ans ende gehen das
ist so ein bisschen den kleiderschrank
darstellen also hier vorne fernseher
hier so ein bisschen garderobe und so
weiter und so fort macht zwar keinen
sinn nicht weiß man geht hier unten rein
und müsste damit seiner jacke bis hier
oben hin bisschen unnötig ich habe auch
schon überlegt ob ich die treppe anders
mache ob ich die von hierhin direkt nach
hinten hin hinziehe allerdings haben wir
diesen kleinen garten nicht mehr so
schön am start aber ihr könnt mir da
auch gerne schreiben ob ihr hier
irgendwas anders bauen würde allerdings
habe ich an der stelle ist heute wie das
auch beendete lieben freunde das hier
unser wohnzimmer ist fertig und hier
vorne hier kommt natürlich auch noch
etwas hin und da kommt noch was rein in
den raum da kommt unser schlafzimmer
hing da kommt auch noch ein fenster rein
meine ich das ist ja gerade hier
ziemlich düster das machen wir der
nächsten folge da könnt ihr euch auf
jeden fall aufbauen die nächste folge
kommt nicht übermorgen online übermorgen
kommt nämlich der patch 1 simulator
online da habe ich viele kommentare
bekommen dass ich das mal wieder
hochladen soll also 1000 simulator also
freut euch auf übermorgen 20 uhr nächste
minecraft folge wenn ihr wissen wollt
nächsten freitag 20 uhr wirklich am
freitag um 20 und nicht ein tag
verspätet von daher meine lieben freunde
wenn ihr euch darauf folgt er lasse
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert main kanal falls man
kann ja der linken seite und klickt auf
die glocke damit ihre neue videos nicht
verpassen eine benachrichtigung kommt
sobald ich neues video hochland ich habe
selbst viel geredet ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder
[Musik]